no radioactive decay of gravitational
radiation they're just like light except
they go through everything so if the
universe produced an enormous amount of
gravitational waves capable of being
detected a billion light years away from
these two black holes that I described
before they were located one billion
light years away in a galaxy we don't
know exactly which Galaxy they were in
but they crashed together in a galaxy
far away from the Milky Way galaxy a
billion years ago those waves of gravity
traveled at the speed of light for a
billion years they entered into two
different telescopes on Earth and they
displaced those telescopes by less than
the diameter of an atom and these
incredible researchers were able to
detect this and they've done it 100
times since so it's a it's a Precision
science just like Galileo first using a
telescope to look at the Moon the moons
of Jupiter the rings of Saturn Etc that
opened up a whole new uh regime of
astronomy not just to look at the moon
but to look at the entire universe using
optical telescopes